michele bachmann has interviewed on fox  news and she says we should be  commending sarah palin for being out  with covet  that's what she said take a look has  different reactions to it but i think  honestly sarah palin is to be commended  because she's trying to act like a  normal human being in the greatest city  in america in new york city she's going  out to eat at a wonderful little  boutique italian restaurant it has  different reactions so that's the view  she should be commended for it now i  wonder like prior to covet right when  during flu season  if michelle bachmann found out  that a republican was out with the flu  eating at restaurants would they say  that's a great heroic thing to do wow we  should we should really commend her for  being out uh  with the flu that that's a really great  thing  this is getting more and more stupid  every day